we all have the urge to explore to give
into curiosity and to turn our lives
into an adventure so why don't you just
go hi guys I am in Germany and look at
this awesome hostel it looks so cool
it's a hospital in clone where all the
hostels are themed and this one's themed
as a ballerina
so far so good
I met someone here at the hostel and
we've been going out to all the
Christmas markets it's been pretty
awesome I'm gonna get to the timbers
museum tomorrow but I hope you enjoyed
the Christmas footage and it's snowing
as well which is perfect I love this
Germany is awesome big thumbs up
you
good morning today I'm gonna attempt to
find the Tim Burton exhibition might get
lost but we'll see how I do on my own
because my sense of direction is awful
so if I can do this you can definitely
do this so yeah let's get let's go find
it and then probably look at more
Christmas markets Museum finally went to
go see it it was amazing I must have
spent about four hours in there but
unfortunately I couldn't take you guys
with me because no cameras and all that
jazz but I found this amazing castle
thing and it's got these awesome grounds
and it was right next to the Tim Burton
Museum so why don't you just come with
me and we can walk around the grounds
together oh so I'm doing their wedding
pictures I'm such a creep
I'll focus anyway I expect like a sea
serpent just poked its head out there
- perfect
Wow
Oh
all right
use this to spy and see if anyone's
behind me because you don't know how
awkward it is to talk to yourself in
front of like a big camcorder as well in
public but it's bad right anyway now
that I'm working in some creepy woods
okay then already that creepy they're
actually quite beautiful but probably
good time to tell you about Tim Burton
exhibition that I just went to it was
amazing it was full of big statues of
his they even had a UV room with like
mr. boogie boogie and all the Scooby
drawings for him and had a huge
screening area where he could see some
of his old films and even some of this
really all just skeptic animation and
stuff which was pretty awesome
I know I've always been a huge fan of
Tim Burton I like how ante grew his
childish imagination kind of stayed and
how it's always been really dark because
I've always had quite a dark imagination
I think a lot of people have to be fair
but we've just been kind of talk to
stifle it because that's not normal you
as a child you should be dreaming of
flying and fairies and unicorns not
really
demented creatures coming after you but
actually they're they're nice they just
seem scary I kind of like how he changed
the way that people thought about horror
yeah it was awesome I wish I could've
showed you more but I totally get why I
couldn't record another but
this walk is so beautiful just look at
it I could have I think I can go in the
building but I think I prefer just
looking around the woods what do you
think the adventure lies outside of our
comfort zones and only we have the
ability to make our dreams turn into
reality so make it happen what have you
got to lose you can live the life you've
always wanted if you just allow it
traveling alone has taught me that money
doesn't always have to be an issue
especially when I find cheap deals
online I think I managed to get flight
tickets that were cheaper than what I
normally spend on a night out also
meeting people is neither hard nor scary
and hostels really are not as bad as TV
makes them out to be I met so many
amazing and unique people on my travels
just from staying in a hostel from
different sides of the world with
different stories to share it reminded
me of just how unique and interesting
every single one of us is and I also
learned a lot about myself as a person
traveling alone isn't always fun it can
be stressful but I understood how I
dealt with those stresses
and it kind of made me feel like a new
me a bit more so if you do have
adventure if you want to go traveling if
you just want to get away nothing
stopping you
well popping yourself you're stopping
you but you you don't have to be
stopping you have a lovely day or
evening bye
you
travel they and conquer baked Canada
your oh no hi guys so we are in our
first hostel and it's cold
hi Niagara